[Musik]
die umwelt mafia zerstört unseren
planeten
wenn wir hier den wald vernichtet dann
sind nicht nur wir mit das betrifft ganz
euro und die ganze erde
kriminelle quellen und töten geschützte
tiere die tiere verdienen das sind und
wir kämpfen für sie mit allem was wir
haben wir müssen dafür sorgen dass die
so förther aufhören
und für fisch den sie über leichen
die mafia ist oft ihr mehr einig der
gerechtigkeit
die umwelt mafia dahinter stecken
kriminelle netzwerke auf der ganzen welt
die für profit die natur ausbeuten und
zerstören
sie agieren im verborgenen und schrecken
auch vor mord nicht zurück
new york city die hauptstadt des
welthandels alexander von bismarck hat
der umwelt mafia den kampf angesagt er
ist einer der weltweit renommiertesten
privaten ermittler im bereich umwelt
kriminalität und leitet eine
internationale umweltorganisation mit
seiner hilfe wollen wir den kriminellen
netzwerken auf die spur kommen weil die
natur oft nicht die höchste priorität
für den zoll ist kann natur die perfekte
schmuggelware für eine mafia
organisation werden man muss sich fragen
wie viel wert sind die letzten wilden
wälder der welt wie viel wert ist die
artenvielfalt wie viel wert sind die
ökosysteme von denen wir alle abhängig
sind
wir zeigen von bismarck unsere
recherchen zu umwelt kriminellen in
urwäldern auf den weltmeeren und im
illegalen tierhandel
kaum jemand kennt die strukturen besser
als er der ermittler arbeitet mit
umweltschützern auf der ganzen welt
zusammen und verspricht auch uns mit
informationen und ratschlägen zu helfen
doch er warnt auch
letztes jahr sind über 200 menschen
getötet worden nur weil sie versucht
haben ihre umwelt zu schützen und wir
können versuchen den beizustehen und
manchmal selber beweise ermitteln das
ist oft mit teil unserer arbeit
dieser mann ist seit zwei jahren spurlos
verschwunden emanuele essien arbeitete
als fischerei kontrolleur für die garage
regierung kämpfte gegen die illegale
ausbeutung der weltmeere seine leiche
wurde nie gefunden
die genauen hintergründe seines
verschwindens sind bis heute unklar
[Musik]
wir reisen nach ghana als heimatland
die küste vor dem westafrikanischen land
ist ein hotspot des illegalen fischfang
viele fischarten sind durch die
skrupellose überfischung vom aussterben
bedroht auf fischtrawler kontrollierte
der fischerei beobachter sn was und
wieviel gefangen wurde um kriminelle
strukturen aufzuspüren
von einer dieser touren kehrte er nie
wieder zurück der kapitän behauptet es
sei ins meer gefallen doch es jens
bruder james ist sicher er lügt
jedes mal wenn ich raus aufs meer
schauen erinnere ich mich an
ein guter mensch
ich bin mir sicher dass sie mein bruder
ermordet
die un geht davon aus dass kriminelle
banden jedes jahr bis zu 20 milliarden
euro mit illegalen fisch verdienen und
wer sich diesen verbrechern auf hoher
see in den weg stellt muss um sein leben
fürchten
sie haben ihn einfach ins meer gebracht
er hatte etwas herausgefunden und wollte
die ergebnisse eigentlich seinen
vorgesetzten übergeben
es ist eine mafia da draußen auf dem
meer
und ich will gerechtigkeit für ihn ein
liter
emanuel essien war oft wochenlang auf
rollern vor ghanas küste unterwegs
nach seinem verschwinden legt ghanas
polizei den fall schnell zu den akten
obwohl es ihn von der regierung
beauftragt worden war
sein bruder will das nicht hinnehmen er
führt uns ins haus der familie
die großmutter kümmert sich jetzt um
emanuel siebenjährige tochter
jeden tag fragt sie nach ihrem vater
die behörden haben uns geld angeboten
als wiedergutmachung sagen sie aber das
geld interessiert mich nicht ich will
keine beschwichtigungen ich will wissen
wo mein sohn ist ich will die wahrheit
erfahren
kurz vor seinem tod habe emmanuel gesagt
dass er sich verfolgt fühle erzählt uns
sein bruder
daher habe er teile seiner
ermittlungsergebnisse versteckt
einen brief haben die essenz gerade erst
entdeckt
er hat also diese notizen kurz vor
seinem tod geschrieben
ganz kurz vor seinem letzten einsatz
in dem brief beschreibt emanuel essen
zahlreiche straftaten auf dem meer und
er bittet die polizei um mithilfe
wenn ich das vorher gefunden hätte hätte
ich ihn nicht mehr aufs meer gelassen
dieses papier hier ist gefährlich
wir machen uns auf den weg zu einem
kleinen fischerhafen wo wir eine
verabredung haben hier sind wir ganz in
der nähe von dem ort an dem emanuel
essien mutmaßlich gestorben ist
irgendwo dort draußen auf dem meer
er verschwand am 5 juli 2009 10 der name
des trawlers engine 15
die investigative journalistin maria
will uns bei unserer spurensuche zum
verschwinden von emanuel es jan
unterstützen seit vielen jahren schon
recherchiert sie zu verbrechen auf dem
meer mindestens zehn fischerei
beobachter seien in den letzten jahren
weltweit spurlos auf hoher see
verschwunden erzählt sie besonders in
ihrer heimat ghana agierten die
kriminellen netzwerke immer skrupelloser
wir sehen gerade wie die lokalen fischer
zurück in den hafen kommen die kommen
mit fast leeren netzen zurück und
gleichzeitig vision die großen fahrer
hier alles leer da können die
einheimischen fischer nicht mithalten
und das schlimmste ist wenn sie hier in
zehn jahren alles leer gefischt haben
suchen sie sich einfach die nächste
region als opfer und wo sollen die
fischer hier in almena dann hingehen
diesen raubbau will marie emma nicht
mehr einfach so hinnehmen denn die
fangmenge ist in den letzten jahren
dramatisch gesunken
gleichzeitig stieg die zahl der
fischerboote für den einheimischen
fischer bleibt immer weniger
wir fahren weiter zum größten
industriehafen ganas wir haben hinweise
bekommen dass hier das schiff liegt auf
dem emanuel essen am tag seines todes
gearbeitet hat
auf dem weg erzählt uns maria von der
gefahr die von der fisch mafia ausgeht
ich bin sogar schon bedroht worden man
kann die anrufe nicht zurückverfolgen
einmal haben sie ein drohbrief im
schulranzen meines sohnes versteckt sie
wollen mich offenbar zum schweigen
bringen
trotz des risikos wollen wir den trailer
finden auf dem emanuel es in seiner
letzten stunden verbrachte eine fast
unmögliche aufgabe aber maria will uns
helfen auch ermittler alexander von
bismarck kennt die machenschaften der
fisch mafia die häfen seien der
flaschenhals den die illegalen waren
passieren müssen bevor sie im normalen
wirtschaftskreislauf landen seit mehr
als 20 jahren ist der ermittler umwelt
verbrechern auf der spur oft undercover
seine erkenntnisse nutzt er um weltweit
für strengere gesetze zu kämpfen dieser
kampf ist ein kampf gegen die
kriminalität und gegen unglaublich viel
power und geld und das führt dazu dass
die leute die vor ort sind und in diesem
kampf um ihre umwelt zu retten
andauernd führen dass die in wahnsinnig
viel gefahr sind und
wir finanzieren das alles mit unserem
bedarf und wir müssen das system ändern
damit wir eine chance haben diese
kriminalität zustimmen
auch in den usa zerstören kriminelle
netzwerke die natur
die so genannten road
kleine privat so sind durch die medien
gegangen
was da berichtet werde stimme so der
ermittler
exotische tiere wie löwen und tiger
sollen gequält und getötet werden
wir wollen mehr wissen fahren zu einem
dieser privathaus als man beim
aussteigen unsere kamera sieht werden
wir bedroht
wer ist scheissegal was du für ein
anliegen hast ich will da nicht
eingezogen werden ich habe schon mal
einen fernsehreporter windelweich
geschlagen langsam werde ich zu alt für
den scheiß aber glaubt mir 1 ich habe
freunde und ich finde dich wo immer du
bist
drohungen und gewalt auch hier in den
usa sollen kritische recherchen offenbar
verhindert werden wir wollen einen der
bekanntesten namen im geschäft zur rede
stellen dr
ihm gehört ein erfolgreicher tiger zoo
in south carolina an der amerikanischen
ostküste
momentan steht ernte vor gericht unter
den 15 anklagepunkten schwere
tierquälerei und illegaler handel mit
wilden tieren
wochen lang ignoriert er unsere
interviewanfragen trotzdem beschließen
wir uns auf den weg nach south carolina
zu machen
zuvor sind wir noch in ecken surfer ab
redet im tiefsten hinterland der
südstaaten
tanya smith und ihr ehemann scott wollen
uns einen einblick in die grausamen
folgen des geschäfts mit exotischen
tieren geben sie haben es sich zur
lebensaufgabe gemacht verbrechen an
wildtieren zu bekämpfen mehr als 150
tiger haben sie in den letzten 25 jahren
befreit dabei gehen sie jedes mal ein
großes risiko ein
manche dieser rettungsaktionen sind sehr
gefährlich das hat nicht nur mit den
wilden tieren zu tun es sind vor allem
die menschen die diese tiere besitzen
oft sind das die gleichen leute die auch
in drogengeschäfte und menschenhandel
verwickelt sind wir haben schon
drohungen bekommen dass die hells angels
es auf uns abgesehen haben natürlich
macht uns das angst aber wir wissen auch
dass die tiere ein solches schicksal
nicht verdient haben und wir tun alles
dafür sie aus diesen situationen heraus
zu holen
die befreiten tiere bringen sie in ihrer
fast 200 hektar großes schutzgebiet
die meisten sorgen machen dem team hier
gerade drei zwölf wochen alte tigerbaby
als sie die tiere aus einem berüchtigten
zoo in oklahoma befreien konnten standen
sie kurz vor dem tod
die drei tiger wurden mit klum füßen
geboren und hätten in dem zoo niemals
über liebt sie hätten sie einfach
getötet
[Musik]
so etwas bringt mir jedes mal das herz
und zu sehen wie sie jetzt selbstständig
laufen können ist wirklich ein wunder
[Musik]
die gründe für die behinderungen der
jungen tiger sind inzucht und
mangelernährung ein problem das ich
während der pandemie noch verschlimmert
hat ohne besucher wurden die tiere zum
reinen kostenfaktor
tierschutzorganisationen berichten von
zwei anlagen mit versteckten gräbern und
unzähligen toten tigern
jedes tier braucht zwischen zwei und
sieben kilo es fleisch und das jeden tag
den meisten besitzern ist es doch
absolut egal wie die tiger ernährt
werden oder was sonst mit ihnen passiert
tanya smith hat besuch von einer
bekannten rechtsanwältin
brittany pete ist zu der hassfigur von
rot zu besitzern geworden
nirgendwo auf der welt werden geschäfte
mit wildtieren so wenig kontrolliert wie
hier in den usa
es fühlt sich oft an als ob wir gegen
eine mafia kämpfen müssen das sind ganze
netzwerke die illegal mit den tieren
handel betreiben es gibt die bekannten
big player wie die exotik dem star cher
flow und die
exotik der durch eine netflix serie
berühmt wurde sitzt inzwischen in haft
doch intel steht vor gericht doch viele
andere sind weiterhin im geschäft
und jede dieser typen sind auch wegen
vieler anderer verbrechen verurteilt
oder werden zumindest beschuldigt die
exotik hat immer gesagt wenn einer
versuchen würde ihm seine tiere
abzunehmen würde er ein massaker
anrichten
die anschuldigungen der
tierschutzverbände streiten sie alle ab
wir fahren weiter nach myrtle beach
einem beliebten ferienort an der
amerikanischen atlantikküste
der ort ist fast ein kleines las vegas
spielcasinos bars unzählige
unterhaltungsangebote eines davon ist
der myrtle beach safaripark der zoo von
dr wir hoffen auch ohne interview einen
einblick zu bekommen
unglaubliche 3 139 us-dollar rund 300
euro kostet eine tagestour
doch vor dem zoo kommen wir schnell an
unsere grenzen mit der kamera kommen wir
nicht weiter bild und tonaufnahmen sind
auf dem gesamten gelände strengstens
verboten
selbst für besucher der anlage
dog and lässt sich offenbar nicht gerne
in die karten gucken durch unsere
recherchen stoßen wir aber auf material
eines us kollegen er hatte mai 2009 10
die möglichkeit offen auf dem gelände zu
filmen er spielt uns material seines
drehs zu
wir trauen unseren augen kaum unzählige
zoo besucher mit kleinen tiger babys auf
dem arm
mehrere us gerichte haben in den
vergangenen jahren in ähnlichen fällen
entschieden dass ein solcher direkter
kontakt zwischen mensch und baby tigern
verboten ist er sei eine gefahr für die
entwicklung der jungen wildtiere und
verstoße gegen us tierschutzgesetze
doch ende hingegen gibt sich als
tierschützer überall auf seiner homepage
wirbt er mit gemeinnützigen
organisationen die ein teil der
einnahmen fließt diese gemeinnützigen
organisationen existieren wirklich
kritiker sehen darin allerdings einen
reinen trick um steuern zu umgehen und
von den wahren geschäften abzulenken
ich glaube dass leute die hoffen dass
sie damit irgendwie den artenschutz
unterstützen bewusst getäuscht werden
sie denken dass das geld tieren in der
wildnis zu gute kommt und das ist
einfach eine lüge in wahrheit kommt das
geld vor allem den betreibern der zoos
zugute und das ist alles ein furchtbarer
teufelskreis
recherchen der us-zeitung des sun times
aus dem jahr 2020 zeigen dass nur ein
bruchteil der stiftungsgelder doppels
tatsächlich an artenschutzprojekte vor
ort gehen der großteil der mittel fließt
in instandhaltung und futter für die
eigenen tiger
tierschützerinnen werfen endl daher vor
sich mit der stiftung lediglich einen
grünen anstrich geben zu wollen wir
konfrontieren eine mitarbeiterin mit den
vorwürfen sie reagiert gereizt
mit unserer organisation unterstützen
wir viele projekte in afrika und asien
für den artenschutz diese tierschützer
sagen ja auch wir sollen keine hamburger
essen und keine haustiere haben schau
doch selbst wie erfolgreich wir bei
instagram und facebook sind die menschen
lieben was wir machen in der tat in
sozialen medien finden sich hunderte
bilder von den umstrittenen
fotoshootings mit baby tigern und sie
bekommen dort tausendfach likes die
selbstinszenierung in sozialen medien
geht auf kosten einer grausamen
ausbeutung der wilden tiere
wie es hinter der fassade aussieht
bekommt kaum jemand zu sehen wir treffen
uns mit einer privat ermittlerin im
auftrag der tierschutzorganisation
humane society hat sie in mehreren
privatzoos undercover beweise gesammelt
auch intels einrichtung
ich konnte mich dort mehrere tage
aufhalten und auch hinter die kulissen
blicken
einmal waren wir in einem raum der wie
ein pferdestall außen
alles dunkel kalt nackter beton boden
neben einem tisch habe ich dann viele
peitschen und ketten entdeckt
für mich lässt das nur einen schluss zu
sie werden zur erziehung der tiger
eingesetzt
wir kontaktieren doppel erneut
wollen wissen was er zu den vorwürfen
sagt doch zu einer offiziellen
stellungnahme ist er nicht bereit
die gerichtlichen untersuchungen gegen
ihn laufen indes weiter auch gegen zwei
familienmitglieder es ist ein
rücksichtsloses millionengeschäft auf
dem rücken geschützter tierarten
verborgen hinter social media likes und
einer kulisse des schönen scheins
der markt von wilden tieren und tier
teilen es viele zehn
milliarden dollar wert jedes jahr und
eines der größten internationalen
kriminellen branchen der welt man muss
strafen haben die hoch genug sind man
muss die beweise sammeln damit die
behörden nicht mehr weg gucken können
zurück in ghana auf den spuren des
verschwundenen fischerei kontrolleurs
emanuel wir suchen in einem hafen
hinweise ob er wirklich von kriminellen
fischern umgebracht wurde hier liegt
irgendwo der trawler den er zuletzt
kontrolliert hat und auf dem er dann
offenbar starb die investigative
journalistin maria bringt uns in den
hafen hinein
box software schaut euch die riesigen
fisch kisten an nur eine davon wäre in
meinem dorf der fahne des jahres für
mindestens fünf boote zusammen
seitdem wir hier stehen sind schon mehr
als 100 dieser kisten entladen worden
und mehr als 70 dieser toller sind jeden
tag unterwegs
der fall emanuel es sei nur ein
unglücklicher unfall gewesen erklärt man
uns hier am hafen er sei von bord
gefallen das schiff selbst können wir
allerdings nicht sehen für den teil des
hafens brauche man angeblich eine
sondergenehmigung
immerhin lässt man uns an bord eines
anderen trainers er ist ähnlich gebaut
wie der auf dem essen verschwand
[Musik]
die brüstung hier ist wahrscheinlich ein
meter 20 hoch glaubst du jemand kann von
hier einfach so ins verfallen
wenn du mich versehentlich schubst alle
ich da nicht einfach so rein
kann der seegang eine rolle gespielt
haben wir schauen uns weiter um tiefer
unter deck wird der fisch sortiert und
direkt eingefroren die crew von rund 30
personen verarbeitet hier mehrere tonnen
pro tag
man kann sich vorstellen wie allein es
ja hier mit seinen untersuchungen
gewesen sein muss mitten auf dem offenen
meer sogar für funksprüche mit dem
festland brauchte er die genehmigung des
kapitäns
hier geht es um andere länder die hier
in ghana wirtschaftliche interessen
haben mit der ausbeutung unserer
ressourcen machen diese firmen ihren
enormen profi
wir verlassen den hafen ein bekannter
von mary emma schickt uns mehrere videos
die illegale aktivitäten oft rollern
dokumentieren sollen das brisante sie
entstanden oft rollern die den gleichen
besitzern gehören wie das schiff auf dem
emanuel es in seinen letzten stunden
verbrachte
die videos sind wichtige belege dafür
dass troja direkt vor der küste illegal
sardinen sardellen und makrelen fischen
die frieren sie dann ein und verkaufen
sie in großen blöcken und mit hohem
profit an lokale händler
für die kleinen fische in ghana bleibt
kaum etwas übrig
hinzu kommt die fische die zu klein für
den illegalen handel sind werden einfach
massenhaft tot ins meer geworfen eine
katastrophe für das ökosystem
diese räuber lassen nichts für die
anderen fischer übrig da geht es nur
darin so viel zu fischen riem möglich
was passiert hier jeden tag niemand
kümmert sich dabei um nachhaltigkeit
doch sind die beteiligten tatsächlich
bereit für ihre kriminellen geschäfte
über leichen zu gehen
wir nehmen kontakt zu einem ehemaligen
kollegen von emanuel essen auf
wir haben gehört dass auch er brisante
informationen hat die ja nur anonym
weitergeben will
auch er hat angst vor der fisch mafia
die sich nicht nur in ghana immer weiter
ausbreitet wir wollen ihnen später
treffen
wahl wo gefischt wird wird auch illegal
gefischt auf ganzer welt ist die
illegale fischerei wird ungefähr von 30
auf 40 prozent geschätzt es ist schon
der fall des die westküste afrikas ein
besonderer hotspot ist aber es ist fast
überall ein problem ein dritter fall
führt uns in die ukraine auf die spuren
der holzmafia
wir reisen in den westen des landes er
ist durchzogen von den karpaten hier
gibt es einige der letzten urwälder
europas sie sind die grüne lunge des
kontinents seit 2007 gehören sie zum
weltnaturerbe der unesco
doch die region ist in gefahr seitdem
die umwelt mafia sie für sich entdeckt
hat
diese urwälder in der ukraine sind ein
weit verzweigtes terrain perfekt für
seltene tierarten aber auch für
kriminelle machenschaften
jedes jahr werden eine million
kubikmeter holz illegal geschlagen so
eine schätzung des wwf holz im wert von
60 millionen euro das in die taschen der
wald mafia fließt das holz landet auch
in unseren wohnzimmern
wir treffen uns mit umweltschützern die
diesen raubbau stoppen wollen ihr ziel
die holzfäller auf frischer tat ertappen
wir müssen noch die offiziellen
datenbanken check habe ich schon gemacht
da ist nicht angemeldet
doch das heißt nicht dass nicht
geschlagen wird die umweltschützer
können uns nicht versprechen dass wir
wirklich auf holzfäller treffen wir
versuchen es trotzdem fahren über
nebenstrecken hinauf in die berge mit
einem alten sowjetischen
truppentransporter der
biologe jörg könig kennt die region
durch viele solcher fahrten
das hier ist einer der abgelegensten
orte in den karpaten
dort hinten ist das format teil das ist
komplett zerstört durch kahlschläge die
keine flächen sind enorm groß so groß
dass die samen der verbliebenen bäume
sich nicht wieder bis zur mitte
ausbreiten kann diese hügel dort hinten
die bleiben carl für jahrzehnte und so
wird überall in der ukraine mit bildern
umgegangen
grünig hat im juni 2021 eine studie
herausgebracht für die er die illegalen
einschläge untersucht hat die holzmafia
in der ukraine habe einen betrug schema
entwickelt um den raubbau legal wirken
zu lassen
wie in jedem anderen gesunden wald gibt
es auch hier in den karpaten alte oder
kranke bäume die kriminellen holzfirmen
bestechen förster und gutachter damit
sie bescheinigen dass das ganze
waldstück krank ist jetzt fällen
holzfäller diese offiziell kranken bäume
das sind sogenannte sanitär habe oft
wird deutlich mehr gefällt als die
ohnehin bestochenen gutachter erlaubt
haben das holz dieser sanitär heber wird
dann regulär verkauft
hier sieht man noch einmal mindestens
drei frische kahlschlag und die sind
illegal und
da hinten ein paar ältere aus den folien
dahinter steckt ein system ein korruptes
system die behörden stecken mit wenn die
polizei die forst administration die
lokalen behörden alle stecken damit
die einzige chance der umweltschützer
holzfäller auf frischer tat erwischen
und beweisen dass sie gesunde bäume
schlagen und wirklich in der ferne hören
wir motorsägen
[Musik]
wir gehen dem geräusch nach die horde
und die anderen sind schneller als wir
mit unserem film equipment nach einem
kurzen abstieg treffen wir sie wieder am
rande einer rodung und
hast du gesehen hast du noch mal was
gehört nein das kam wohl von einer der
hütten auf der anderen bergseite
an diesem hang wurde schon vor einigen
monaten geschlagen und auf die andere
seite da wo das geräusch herkommt kommen
wir zu fuß nicht schnell genug hinüber
dieser holzfäller denken der wald gehöre
ihnen und wir sind für sie einfach nur
eindringlinge liegen ihre einkommens
grundlage zerstören letztes jahr hatten
wir drei zusammenstöße bei denen die
holzfäller richtig aggressiv wurden sie
meinten sie würden uns umbringen und
wenn wir nicht aufpassen kämen wir nicht
mehr nach hause
die aggressivität hat einen grund
die holzfäller fürchten schärfere
kontrollen
der biologe jörg benik schätzt dass
zwischen 60 und 80 prozent der sanitär
hiebe in der ukraine illegal sind das
illegal geschlagene holz wird mit
falschen dokumenten versehen und
zertifiziert
wenn also jemand in deutschland zb ein
stuhl kampf dieser stuhl offiziell
zertifiziert wurde und denkt der käufer
dass er ein nachhaltiges produkt kauft
aber in wirklichkeit kommt das holz aus
diesen urwäldern hier
die horde gibt nicht auf er will mit uns
auf der anderen seite des tages weiter
suchen das katz und maus spiel geht in
die zweite runde viele gute leute
arbeiten an zertifikaten aber leider im
jetzigen system denen sie hauptsächlich
dazu die eigentliche herkunft und die
illegalität von vielen holz weiß zu
waschen
europa hat eigentlich eingesetzt das
nicht erlaubt dass illegales holz
importiert werden darf aber weil das
holz dieses zertifikat hat fsc darf es
relativ ungeprüft in europa einfließen
der illegale einschlag ist so profitabel
dass ich kaum jemand die mühe macht
legal zu schlagen darunter leiden
ehrliche unternehmer
wir treffen wolodimir fabrizio einen
sägewerksbesitzer
der wald wird in unserer region
regelrecht vernichtet niemand will legal
arbeiten wir nehmen hier kein illegales
holz deswegen sind unsere lager auch
lehrer die anderen die das illegale holz
verarbeiten die machen geld die haben
aber wir nicht dann kaufen sie falsche
herkunfts bescheinigungen und verkaufen
das holz ins ausland entweder nur die
hohen stimme oder zugeschnittene bretter
das wird so exportiert aber es ist alles
falsch zertifiziert das ist gestohlenes
illegal geschlagenes holz
verriet sie und sein kompagnon weil die
pass lueg machen nicht mit beim raubbau
und sie arbeiten mit den umweltschützern
zusammen deswegen wurden sie schon
mehrfach bedroht und sogar angegriffen
wie dieses video der umweltschützer
dokumentiert unter den angreifern
befindet sich sogar ein bekannter
lokalpolitiker keiner der angreifer
wurde verurteilt trotz des videos
wenn die so weitermachen bleibt in ein
oder zwei jahren nichts mehr zum fällen
übrig
dann kommen die katastrophen wie
überschwemmungen und waldbrände
wenn wir hier den wald zerstören dann
sind aber nicht nur wir betroffen das
betrifft ganz europa den ganzen planeten
weil die karpaten eine grüne lunge sei
die zerstörung in den karpaten ist nur
ein kleiner teil der abholzung von
urwäldern weltweit
jahr für jahr verlieren wir zehn
millionen hektar die fläche von portugal
rund 150 milliarden euro verdienen die
skrupellosen geschäftemacher jährlich
daran
der nächste morgen wir sind wieder mit
den umweltschützern in den wäldern
unterwegs doch die chancen holzfäller zu
erwischen sind gesunken wir befürchten
dass wir gestern aufgeflogen sind unsere
große gruppe ist so auffällig
wir haben heute morgen noch einmal die
satellitenbilder gecheckt
ich bin nicht 100 sicher aber es gibt
ein paar möglichen stehen jetzt aber
dürfen jetzt schon ja das ist schon
möglich lasst es uns einfach versuchen
schau mal her
habt ihr das gesehen es ist illegal den
fluss so zu durchqueren absolut verboten
dieser holzlaster hat eben einen fluss
passiert er kommt aus dem waldgebiet aus
dem wir gestern die motorsägen gehört
haben
offenbar wird dort doch noch gefällt
die fahren einfach so durch den fluss
das ist illegal in der ukraine einfach
so durch das flussbett zu fahren
wir fahren weitere 5 km das tal hinauf
hier wird nach aussagen der
umweltschützer am meisten illegal
gefällt an einem checkpoint treffen wir
tatsächlich einige holzfäller die
horrorklinik will sie zur rede stellen
wo gibt s denn illegalen einschlag es
gibt illegale sanitär habe bei denen
gesunde bäume gefällt wie er sonst
erhebe sind legal aber nicht bei
gesunden bäumen wir halten uns an die
vorschriften schlagen sie gesunde bäume
es läuft alles nach vorschrift wo wird
denn illegal geschlagen zeigen sie es
als sie kommen hier mit diesen blödsinn
an und machen hier so einen zirkus dann
sagen sie also dass sie nie gesunde
bäume bei sanitär ihnen schlagen wir
schlagen und wir pflanzen oder ist doch
keine ahnung von den vorschriften doch
ich kenne sie ganz gut
wie horn lässt nicht nach die holzfäller
werden langsam wütend
wir verdienen unser geld mit dieser
arbeit der wald gehört auch uns nicht
nur dem start der staat das sind doch
wie er das volk wir haben das recht ihr
holz zu schlagen und zu verkaufen
was macht ihr eigentlich
wie erwartet von reichen leuten
geschichten
irgendwelchen millionärin mit millionen
dollar in der tasche
und ein förster bei uns verdienen 5000
real monat wie kann man denn davon leben
5.000 kwh im jahr entsprechend etwa 160
euro es ist die armut die die holzfäller
antreibt illegal zu fällen doch der
großteil des einkommens der holzmafia
landet bei anderen korrupten gutachtern
der polizei staatlichen kontrolleuren
und oberförster
während wir diskutieren fahren weitere
holzlaster an uns vorbei
auch wir wollen weiter das tal hinauf
doch dann steht ein holzlaster quer auf
der straße
ja wir können jetzt nicht mehr in den
wald fahren die straße ist blockiert sie
behaupten dass der lkw kein benzin mehr
hat das ist uns schon öfter passiert wir
haben hier nicht durch die holzfäller
blockieren die straße noch mit einem
zweiten lastwagen
angeblich auf anweisung des oberförster
hier kommen wir nicht weiter wir treten
den rückzug an
das größte problem ist wir gehen in den
wald dokumentieren alles illegale
rodungen im wert von millionen von
dollar aber es passiert nichts ich
schreibe berichte über eine anzeige
schreibe der umwelt aus sicht spreche
mit abgeordneten aber es passiert nichts
denn alle verdienen hier mit das ist ein
total korruptes system und niemand
interessiert sich dafür was ihr
umweltschützer alexander von bismarck
hat dem system der holzmafia schon
länger den kampf angesagt
auch dank seiner organisation gibt es
zumindest in den usa strenge gesetze zur
einfuhr von holz deren einhaltung
inzwischen auch besser kontrolliert wird
doch für von bismarck muss sich noch
mehr ändern wenn wir als käufer nichts
anderes verlangen dann wird die einzige
regel die gewinnt wird die gewinns regel
den gewinn zu maximieren führt dazu
illegale produkte zu kaufen die sind
billiger
zurück in ghana
wir wollen verstehen unter welchen
umständen fischerei beobachter emanuel
essien ums leben gekommen ist in einer
leeren lagerhalle am hafen treffen wir
uns mit einem ehemaligen kollegen von
ihm er will nicht erkannt werden die
kriminellen auf dem meer kennen keine
gnade sagt er
auf hoher see bist du ganz allein ohne
kollegen oder sicherheitskräfte die dir
helfen könnten
vor allem die chinesen sind schwer zu
kontrollieren die sind übel trifft wenn
du versuchst ihre aktivitäten zu
dokumentieren fangen sie an dich gezielt
zu bekämpfen
auch an bord des schiffs auf dem emanuel
es in seinen letzten einsatz hatte waren
die wichtigsten crewmitglieder chinesin
li na ist zur weltweit größten fischfang
nationen aufgestiegen
manchmal kommen sie an und sagen ich geb
dir so und so viel geld oder ändern so
und so großen anteil an unserem fall
wenn du steigst vor allem wenn der
kapitän mitbekommt dass du videos oder
fotos machst wird er nervös
erst versuchen sie es dann mit
bestechung es sind typische
mafiamethoden
wenn du nicht auf ihr angebot eingehe
ist oder wenn du nicht genau aufpasst
dann machen sie dich kalt wir kämpfen
fast alle arrangierten sich irgendwann
mit den verhältnissen so der informant
nur nicht emanuel essen er habe sich nie
korrumpieren lassen
du warst auch auf schiffen unterwegs auf
denen emanuel gearbeitet hat oder
ich war auf der mansion 2 letztes jahr
noch die sind weiterhin in illegalen
fischfang involviert ich bin mir sicher
sie haben ihn entdeckt wir heimlich
aufnahmen gemacht hat
und der einfachste weg in loszuwerden
war ihn umzubringen und dann einfach ins
meer zu werfen
wie kann die ganze crew an bord sein
inklusive der chinesen also mindestens
20 personen und angeblich hat keiner
etwas mitbekommen das ist einfach
unmöglich
wir kontaktieren die firma canon bohnert
fische ries dieser firma gehört das
schiff menschen 15 auf dem emanuel
verschwand
zusammen mit journalistin maria wollen
wir die verantwortlichen mit den
anschuldigungen konfrontiert
aber wir scheitern
dafür bekommen wir einen termin bei der
zuständigen direktoren im
fischereiministerium
sie verblüfft uns mit einer frappierend
ehrlichen antwort warum die familie noch
nicht entschädigt wurde
wir wollten der familie von sn vor
einiger zeit eigentlich eine
entschädigung zahlen aber ein anwalt
meinte wir sollen das lassen weil wir
dann zugeben dass da etwas passiert ist
wir haben aber wirklich nicht aufgehört
zu ermitteln wir sind da immer noch dran
die erklärung klingt für uns hilflos
über zwei jahre nach emanuel es jens
todt sind die hintergründe nicht
aufgeklärt und auch wir kommen in diesem
konkreten fall nicht weiter
eines ist aber klar beim großen geschäft
mit dem fischfang sind internationale
player am werk
ken bohnert fische ries ist eine
scheinfirma sie gehört einem
chinesischen konzern
dailymotion fischer ries
dem besitzer dieses konzerns gehören
mindestens 20 troller in ghana sie
fischen dort das mehr leer doch alle
kontaktversuche auch über chinesische
mittelsmänner bleiben unbeantwortet
alexander von bismarck ist sich sicher
ja also scheinfirmen und
briefkastenfirmen illustrieren
eigentlich das grundproblem im
welthandel man kann mit absolut
illegaler ware anfang und dann
irgendwann hat man eine eine scheinfirma
und die namen ändern sich und irgendwann
sagen die besitzer einer firma ich hatte
keine ahnung es ist eine fesche und
legaler fisch ich wusste es nicht die
naturprodukte sind halt gestohlen sie
sind im endeffekt von uns allen
gestohlen und das endresultat ist dass
wir die natur selber verlieren
marie emma gibt nicht auf sie hofft auf
den internationalen markt und auf europa
der fisch bleibt ja nicht in ghana er
wird überall auf der welt war man muss
genau verfolgen wohin geht wenn die eu
härter durchgreifen und einige importe
verbieten würde wäre das ein wichtiges
zeichen dann könnte man sich endlich
zusammen setzen und neue wege finden
gemeinsam könne man die umwelt mafia
stoppen so mary emma
globale verbrechen könne nur global
bekämpft werden das findet auch umwelt
ermittler alexander von bismarck er
sieht vor allem die großen
wirtschaftsmächte in der pflicht es gibt
in europa und in amerika ansätze um
gesetze durchzubringen die verlangen
würde das genau im beweise wo die
produkte eigentlich herkommen vorhanden
sein müssen und sonst dürfen die
produkte nicht importiert werden zb
das könnte die welt ändern wenn wir uns
zusammentun und das von den größten
konzernen die wahrscheinlich etwas geld
verlieren werden müssen verlangen
für die menschen die der umwelt mafia
den kampf angesagt haben steht weit mehr
auf dem spiel als etwas geld es geht um
ihr leben
überall auf der welt riskieren mutige
ermittler journalisten und aktivisten
tag für tag fiel damit wir weiterleben
kann
denn die verbrechen der kriminellen
netzwerke betreffen unseren wohlstand
unsere umwelt
wenn wir uns ihn nicht entschlossen in
den weg stellen ist unser planet als
ganzes in gefahr
[Musik]